one of the things we do around here at
corridor crew is give you guys an
appreciation for the art and the craft
of filmmaking and part of that
appreciation comes from an understanding
so today we're doing the jackie chan
olympics we've done other celebrity
olympics around here in the past in fact
nico holds the title for office tom
cruise sam holds the title for office
indiana jones and today we compete for
the title of office jackie chan
now with sam and nico already holding
office titles we brought in two extra
players to help round out the
competition we've got d from node and
we've got wes who's an awesome filmmaker
and creator you may have seen his stuff
on instagram or on facebook or you may
have caught him right here on the
corridor cast i've got a bunch of
jackies around me which jackie are you
so today i'm coming in with jackie chan
from wheels on meals i'm asian lee from
rush hour the best draggy chan movie in
my opinion i'm rumbling the bronx jackie
all the way
drunken master chunky chad
see no one's no one's representing older
jackie so that's what i am i'm i'm the
foreigner i'm i'm wise and old jackie
chan i'm so glad that we decided to do
this because i'm gonna win this whole
thing guys wow you hear that confidence
i think there's a lot more competition
here today than he realized myself
included i'm gonna win it for sure i was
raised in japan really yeah i grew up in
okinawa
oh
now in order to make this jackie chan
official we've set up several challenges
inspired directly from his movies let's
get started the first challenge is a
simple kip up from the ground onto your
feet that's right simple simple jackie
chan does this he gets knocked over and
he does this perfect beautiful kip up
back onto his feet and he keeps fighting
why is it called kip up not kick up
ketchup i don't know oh ketchup ketchup
you're kicking and you're flipping so
it's a kickflip it's a kick it's a
kickflip
a flicko which just sounds noticeable no
it's not school each person's only gonna
get three tries to do this so the worst
person will be eliminated perfect
perfect clint i think since you're the
most hyped about this you gotta go first
man all right let's go let's go
let's go
three two one go
pretty good
i didn't think you were going to do that
that well on the first time so silence
that was so easy that was it was almost
dead silent that is really good i was
pretty good it's pretty nice i think i'm
going to add some sauce yeah
wes wants it
let's see it he's ready for this
and
three two one go
whoa whoa
the three-point landing is pretty clutch
too yeah oh man can you do a kick-up i
used to be able to do hip-hop i haven't
done one in a really long time either
rumble in the bronx jackie when it's all
in the line let's get this jackie come
on jacob let's go grab my jacket
all right ready
[Music]
[Music]
come on come on jackie
that's that's the closest i've probably
ever gotten though i summoned all of my
jackie's strength i feel like i could
get it after three i don't know it's
been a long time
all right good luck tucker wait
[Music]
[Applause]
that was not very clean but i did it
all right good luck it's between me and
you man whoever does it worse i'm hoping
old man jackie it doesn't have what he
used to have
all you gotta do is when you go back you
gotta pop your front four roll on to
that and then when you do it snap that
[Music]
see forward in your head and then be
like i can do it and then you do it
here it goes
[Applause]
[Music]
ejected himself from the competition
ren is out there he's he's in studio
city now yeah i didn't see him some say
he's still trying to kip off yeah i'll
take it man i'll take it let's move on
to the next challenge all right so in
most jackie chan movies you'll see
jackie running up a wall and grabbing a
high ledge in order to escape the bad
guys or maybe as a diversion through a
chase scene so that's what we're doing
here today we're at this wall we're
gonna grab some yellow gaff wall run up
this thing slap a piece at the top
whoever gets the highest wins we're also
taking into account number of steps on
the wall and of course style points
because it is a jaggy chain competition
ready all right ready be one with the
wall here we go
[Music]
that's pretty good man okay now
technically that's only half stuck up
there no it's
looks like it's 125 and a half
i'll give it a shot little known fact
jake's name does start with a j the same
letter in jackie's first name so
that's not bad i'll take it that's
definitely good i'll take it
that's 120 and a half i was not
expecting jake to do that well all right
okay jackie good luck thank you jackie
[Applause]
i smack my knee into the wall again is
jackie okay yeah jackie's all right
119 and a half so far wes is in first
with 125 and a half i'm in second with
120 and a half decent third with 119 and
a half we'll see how clint fares
it's all up to him now i'm going to the
top
[Applause]
dude i think clint was definitely the
winner here sorry jackie was the winner
here jackie was second place and jackie
was third place and jackie was fourth
place jackie also lost sorry jackie
at least you have a good retirement with
the force
but we have you guys as judges and what
better than to have the two oldest
jackies being the judges with all that
wisdom let's move on that is so good
dude this was such a good show i know it
was the best jackie
you just under you i'm close we were
just doing some research on different
jackie chan challenges and we realized
that jackie is always very very close
with his uncle no matter if it's the
animated show or if it's rumble on the
bronx he's constantly yelling out uncle
i'll go i'll go i'll go i'll go
and i figured that is a great leg up for
me because i bet you out of everyone
here in the office i am closest with my
uncle i haven't talked to my uncle years
i don't even know you're still alive
yeah how close you were i just talked to
my uncle yesterday how close are you to
the uncle i'm very close with my uncles
oh look guys here's the guarantee i am
the closest my uncle call him right now
first ring first ring put him on speaker
really
uncle jack
uncle jack
he usually picks up
wow one ring uncle jack what's up man
it's been been uh i guess since
yesterday
today we're just here doing like a
jackie chan challenge that reminded me
i'll give you a call and uh that's great
yeah yeah anyway as long as we're on the
subject of the videos um your mom wanted
me to tell you to tell the audience
about today's sponsor rage shadow legend
did you do that yet how do you know
about today's sponsor yeah the brand new
free to play rpg taking the mobile
gaming lands date by storm got almost 10
million players worldwide man you got
over 400 champions you can gather orcs
undead knights elves and more i mean
i've been playing
scratch out of this game it's been
fantastic i mean you can assemble teams
and play as factions you can enjoy a
fully voiced over story campaign i mean
it's just love but don't take my word
for it there's been over 200 000 reviews
all positive of course clint has no way
that's your uncle what do you think
about that i just think that's very odd
and very specific i didn't talk to jake
or anything but he said go to the
description of this video click the
links and for people that are new
they'll get 50 000 silver and a free
epic champion to start with your jacket
man uh real quick just one last one last
question for you um where are you right
now
um i'm uh in my lounge
all right bye-bye
you guys heard it raid shadow legends
download it it's a good time
yo jake can i see your your phone real
quick why
did you change my uncle's number to your
number
let me see your phone please you're not
touching it quack
okay the next challenge is the obstacle
course now in every jackie chan movie
he's going under something he's going
over something he's hopping into cars
through windows and this challenge is
directly inspired by those moments
you're gonna start here at the cone
you're going to go this way over
the first saw horse under the second
without spilling any water and then to
the car through the window and into the
seat
and honk the horn time stops when you
honk the horn may the fastest man win
all right so jackie from wheels on meals
is up first gotta be quick the water
part is the part i am most worried about
like how am i gonna sneak under that
without knocking any water down
i'm also kind of scared this guy look at
these abs man look at that whoa see i
don't have those man i got like a pack i
got a pack all right clint you're gonna
go start at the cone i'm gonna yell
three two one go the timer will start on
go and it will keep going until you honk
the horn i'm ready
ready
what 6.19 that was ridiculous
that's how it's done that was so fast
wow all right i'm gonna try it see i'm
playing it up because the guys don't
know that i was a division one two-time
all-american in track and field and i
also did the steeplechase so jumping
over things not a problem for me
with those jeans
[Music]
zero eight seconds faster wow oh you
forgot
i'm a two-time division one all-american
and i still can't do a keep up i am
nervous i'm legit nervous do you think
you can eliminate coins uh you know what
i'm visualizing it right now all right
good luck jackie thank you jackie
[Music]
5.98
i thought i could do it wes you had so
much height over the first saw horse
clint you are honorable in victory as
well as defeat i wish you both the best
in the final challenge thank you
guys welcome to the finals we have two
born and bred jackies right in front of
us here this is a very very special
final competition here this is time out
you all remember the scene and drunken
master when uh jackie acts up and gets
put in timeout by his dad that's what
we're doing here today we're gonna
balance five cups of water one on the
head two on the shoulders two on the
knees fill it with very hot boiling
water first person to spill any of the
water or fall down from muscle fatigue
loses and the other person is crowned
it's office jackie chan let's get to it
you made it this far man i made it this
far my first day i've been doing martial
arts my whole life horse dances is like
walking
i'm meditating very hard
but i'm thinking confident thoughts
the whole idea of this is to be able to
keep your cool under any obstacle that
comes your way
[Music]
bruce lee always said be like water
be water my friend and our bodies are 90
water yeah whoever wins this is going to
be the office jackie chan i'm sad it's
not me the only asian person in the
office
we're taking the wigs off for the ease
of the water placement on the head
all right shoulders are set
[Music]
one box off the box knees are on you
guys are good that's it that's it all
right we're in all right
wes has a really nice solid low stance
but there's shoulders jake also has the
jackie shoes on oh i see some wobble
right here we've got some web blobs
going on on this water right here jake
is concentrating with his eyes closed
he's trying so hard wes is solid as a
rock jake's wobbling a little bit but he
he's got the soul of a warrior
he's got the soul of a warrior
no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the office jackie isn't even normally in
this office unless he's crowned office
jackie
office jacket
i mean honestly guys like cordura
digital is probably my favorite channel
on youtube so um being part of the
legacy
since you are the winner of the jackie
chan office challenge you are
legally now allowed to wear any
jack-and-chan costume and no one can
question it congratulations you have
been a true honor i thank you guys
thank you jackie i'm not worthy of this
windbreaker
it's a good day seeing a man win the
celebrity olympics
now we have an office tom cruise an
office indiana jones an office jackie
chan if you have an idea on another
movie star olympics you think we should
do let us know in the comments below
we'd love to check it out
you guys have an office mr bean office
mr bean office john goodman